[Música]
cada dos años durante tres días decenas
de globos invaden el cielo durante la
copa de europa de globos aerostáticos
48 equipos participan en esta
competencia atípica
14 naciones están representadas
efe
primer día de competencia los
organizadores prueban el clima con este
pequeño globo
dios
54 inicio
163 calculan la fuerza y la dirección de
los vientos
un 31
mi papel es definir si se puede volar de
manera segura
el viento no puede ser superior a cierta
velocidad y su dirección debe ser esta
la dirección tras la verificación del
clima el director de los vuelos inicia
la competencia
sin desata capucine de sad es piloto una
de las tres mejores en francia esta es
su sexta participación prepara su vuelo
antes de lanzarse
verificamos si el quemador funciona bien
a la izquierda emma la pequeña hermana
de capucine a la derecha carolyn su
suegra preparación rápida para este
equipo entrenado
a mí
carolyn tratan de seguir a capucine no
perderla de vista para ayudarla a
navegar
[Música]
no me voy a hacer desplazar a la
izquierda
capucine y su navegador a djukic tratan
de dirigir el globo aeroestático lo
mejor que pueden sin trato trato
entendiste es lo que dije si asimile lo
que me dijiste marta aún no he pasado
el pilotaje en globo es un arte sutil
hay que saber jugar con los diferentes
corredores de viento se dieron cuenta
que en tierra la dirección del viento
las llevaba lo más a la izquierda
posible y subiendo hay un corredor de
viento diferente y así puedes
desplazarte a la izquierda oa la derecha
una vez en el aire los equipos deben
alcanzar los blancos fijos en tierra
el objetivo es lanzar su marcador lo más
cerca posible del centro de esta cruz
como con los dardos
ahora es el turno de capucine y youtube
necesito ver el blanco porque aquí no me
doy cuenta justo arriba está el campo a
la izquierda de acuerdo intento y trato
de no mostrar mucho tampoco
voy a tratar de no ir mucho hacia la
derecha porque de lo contrario no voy a
poder descender sobre el blanco
descendimos muy tarde
esta vez no dieron en el blanco la
carrera de la mañana ha terminado
capuchino ya casi actualizamos los ven
ahora no las veo pero sé dónde están
el equipo tal vez podrá mejorar en las
próximas pruebas
todo salió bien
sí muy bien bueno estamos cansadas yo
también no puedo más
tras el almuerzo los equipos salen de la
siesta durante los tres días de
competencia hay varias pruebas los
pilotos deben aprender a gestionar la
fatiga
si se maneja bien el ritmo normalmente
no nos cansamos salimos casi descansados
de la competencia bueno hay que llevar
la última prueba de la competencia tiene
lugar cuando cae la noche
los competidores tienen una hora para
llegar al blanco
en tierra los organizadores vigilan el
rendimiento de los candidatos
el blanco está disponible hasta la caída
del sol es decir hasta las 21 horas 30 y
el problema es que si lanzan después de
esa hora no tienen resultados
capucine y yuki están en la quinta
posición en el ranking femenino se
acerca el último blanco cuánto tiempo
falta para terminar la prueba todo se
juega ahora nos quedan 20 minutos el
amarillo que desciende es aquí desde el
amarillo porque aquí estamos en todo el
eje lo lograremos
si debes pasar la línea del campo
el lanzamiento es perfecto al 32
centímetros del centro del blanco tras
un inicio regular el primer día el
equipo de capucine queda de tercero en
el ranking femenino la próxima cita es
dentro de dos años para tratar de
obtener el título